hi brethren its Lisa today I bring you
part two in my four-part series the
pearl of great price if you haven't seen
the first part part 1 persecution please
go back and see the 17 minute long
presentation before you watch this one
there are four parts and they are
specifically put in this order to bring
the whole or the sum of the
understanding that I have been receiving
from Father in this lesson so today we
will go over who is the Beast and how is
it that he overcomes the Saints that is
a very good question and I will cover
that with you and what father has shown
me over this long study so join me and I
hope you enjoy the study
who is the Beast how is it that he will
overcome the Saints the basic premise is
as clear as can be those who do not
follow the Beast the Saints will be
greatly persecuted revelation 13:2 7 the
Beast I saw resembled a leopard but had
a that had feet like those of a bear and
a mouth like that of a lion the dragon
gave the Beast his power and his throne
and great Authority one of the heads of
the Beast seemed to have a fatal wound
but the fatal wound had been healed the
whole world was filled with wonder and
followed the Beast people worshiped the
dragon because he had given authority to
the Beast and they also worshiped the
Beast and asked who was like the Beast
an important thing to know ears people
worshiped the dragon in verse 4
revelation 13 verse 4 worshiped the
dragon because he had given authority to
the Beast
and they worship the beasts and ask who
is like the Beast so people are thinking
that this beast is something great who
was like him who could possibly be like
him who can wage war against him
the beast was given amount to other
crowd words and blasphemies and to
exercise his authority for 42 months it
opens its mouth to blaspheme God and to
slander his name and his dwelling place
and those who live in heaven it was
given to power to wage war against God's
holy people and to conquer them it was
in this is in verse 7 it was given power
to him to wage war against God's holy
people and to conquer them
God's holy people were not gone or taken
away
waged war against God's holy people it
says in Daniel that he overcame the
Saints of the Most High and overcame
them
here it says conquered them and it was
given authority over every tribe people
language and nation every tribe people
language and nation how did the Saints
prevail how do they prevail how do they
ever come so to prevail is to overcome
overcome your enemies prevail over your
enemies the Antichrist will overcome us
physically but he will not overcome us
spiritually as we will overcome him by
what the blood of the Lamb and the word
of our testimony and we will not live
our lives even unto the death do you not
fear who can kill the body but fear Him
who can kill the body and throw the soul
into hell so it's saying don't don't
fear those who can kill this flesh body
because this flesh body can't inherit
the kingdom anyway when you overcome you
overcome when you overcome this flesh
someone comes and kills you because you
refuse to worship the name of Jesus you
have overcome by the blood of the Lamb
not by your own blood but by the blood
of the Lamb you have sold everything
including your you've handed it all over
you don't want anything to do with this
wicked world anyway you want to advance
to the kingdom you've overcome this
world they've taken your life so the
enemy will not overcome us physically
the enemy will overcome us physically it
will overcome the Saints the Word says
that over and over and over and over
again and Daniel 7 it tells you that he
overcomes the Saints until the Ancient
of Days comes he will not overcome us
spiritually though
there's a difference and the word tells
us that difference that we love not our
lives under death because we fear not
those who can kill the body who overcame
it physically but we fear the one who
can kill both body and soul and throw
into hell we fear the Lord God the great
I am the first and last the Alpha and
Omega in the beginning in the end we
fear Him most people don't want to hear
this they just don't want here but this
is the love of the truth 2nd
Thessalonians and many will receive a
strong delusion and not be not be
prepared in their hearts to pick up
their cross and follow Jesus and endure
to the end what is the end at the end of
them the end of the tribulation when the
Ancient of Days comes and pours his
breath out on the world so many will see
receive a strong delusion and not be
prepared in their hearts to pick up
their cross and follow Jesus and endure
they would rather be rescued from their
troubles and this is exactly the
delusion and I would have blood on my
hands I would have blood on my hands if
I wasn't obedient to father with what he
has shown me and come forth and tell you
I will tell you that right now
if I refused to bring forth this message
when he was putting it heavily on my
heart we were about to enter really dark
days he wants his bride his children to
be prepared in full armor and be able to
stand and endure in the day of evil and
he who endures to the end shall be saved
that this is by the Word of God I'm not
making any of this up
he is just laying it out before me
because I
I wanted to know more about the pearl of
great price the greatest love ever told
the greatest love ever shown so most
people don't want to hear because they
want to be rescued from their troubles
and this is exactly the delusion you may
not believe me now but when the time
comes and you find yourself in this
position just as many others have to
this day even while we speak someone is
being martyred today for their faith in
Jesus Christ instead of you being one of
those that are part of the great falling
away I want you to think back on this
when you're standing in that moment and
all hell has broken loose on the face of
this earth and you're standing there
thinking but I thought we were gonna be
raptured before any of this came many
will be falling away many will be
standing around you going so where is
the promise of his coming
I thought your God was gonna come rescue
you where's the promise of his coming so
you may not believe me down but you're
gonna find yourself in this position if
you don't prepare now instead of you
being one of those that are part of the
great falling away I want you to
remember this conversation and the word
I have instructed to give I've been
instructed to give by father as the day
quickly approaches I want you to
remember and pick up your cross no
matter how difficult and follow Jesus
not loving your life into death and you
will be counted in the overcomers and
receive your reward in heaven the strong
delusion I believe has a lot to do with
these rapture teaching because I truly
believe see I'm not one who doesn't
believe in the rapture I believe that
the Lord will come and gather his Saints
at the last rung as the Lord sets second
Corinthians 15:54 at the last Trump in
the twinkling in the twinkling of an eye
in a moment in the twinkling of an eye
the dead in Christ shall rise first and
then we who are alive and remain and
remain we will be changed
in a moment in the twinkling of an eye
at the last Trump where's the last Trump
revelation 11 18 or 19 right in there so
this is teaching for the past 200 years
it's really taken precedence in our
churches people who used to preach about
faith and enduring and suffering for the
name of Jesus Christ and our churches
were full of repenting and calling
people to repentance and change lines
and and suffering for the name of Christ
and standing in full armor and having
faith in enduring no matter what today's
churches the rapture is gonna be here
before any trouble happens and you know
we're just gonna keep being great
everything's gonna go back to normal the
Lord is gonna bless america let me tell
you one thing right now the Lord is not
blessing America right now he is holding
back the hand of his judgment and it's
coming his birth pangs upon the land to
give the people a chance to repent the
blood of 60 some-odd million children
cry out from the ground of those
including myself before I was saved who
offered the children up to bail by
abortion the unnatural affections the
good standing for evil and the evil
standing for good it's not cool in this
country to be straight anymore
it's not cool in this country to be a
Christian it's not cool in this country
to stand for the truth in the name of
Jesus Christ actually now it's
considered hate speech I'm telling you
about the love of Christ and the
redeeming quality of the blood of the
Lamb who wants to save you from your sin
a Christian nation who was built on
supposedly prison biblical principles is
now calling what we're preaching hate
speech and we will be stopped soon and I
was told there was a timely this was a
timely message to bring forth
if the Lord prompts you to share this
word with someone this message and you
don't do it because you don't want
anyone thinking bad of you or well they
think I believe you know that you know I
don't want those people to think this I
mean they're gonna think you know this
one was crazy I'm telling you the Lord
called me in 2017 Ezekiel 33 I may be a
woman but he specifically outright
called me to be a watchman on the wall
in heaven there is normal nor female
your is the angels
no marriage no giving a marriage no male
nor female Norval nor free no judo
ginger how rich or poor
when he calls us to bring forth the
message it is because the heroin that he
first called left the sheep they were
more concerned about big buildings many
riches
Jets
travel
unfortunately those hireling left the
sheep and they preached a doctrine under
a 501c3 organization which is under
government rule and put off talking
about judgment in the day of the Lord
because they were serving itching ears
and they knew they had to appease the
crowd big blue and pink lights
entertainment full bands money money
money tell you I have no money but I got
a phone with a camera on it any youtube
channel for now and the Lord will
preserve this message until it's such
time we will no longer be able to bring
you these messages and if you don't heed
the call now to turn your life over to
Jesus Christ and to prepare your heart
for tribulation in this life you will
have tribulation
are you willing to give all you have
for the pearl of great price death is
what the kingdom of heaven is likening -
it's not escaping with no trouble well
all your brothers and sisters around the
world are being martyred brutally
martyred daily and are you praying for
them
are you praying for them
because when this starts going on here
you're gonna hope to the Lord that
they're praying for you
there's a scripture that's coming to
mind about being out right now about
being double-minded go to the Lord in
prayer believe me when I first got saved
I first received the Holy Spirit it was
by His grace and his love he had to call
my name I sure wasn't looking he had to
come get this blind fool but he did he
reached in the very sinful place those
scriptures where you reach into the very
fire hating the very garments he reached
his arm and there to get me
for me to live it's Christ for me to die
his game but while I live I will live
for Christ
I will live by my testimony I will live
by the Word of God I will speak it and I
love him
because he surely left me
and if he can love me and come pick me
up out of that was what my life is like
if he can save me he can save you
that's League
I am playing with a country
that will continue to fall and no one
most won't listen
it won't even hear it
the Bible said they would
but I pray you're one that does
well says that many the majority will
not listen but I pray that you
wonders
right now but he pours himself on you
then he pours his spirit on you
and that you get a loan with him
and you have a divine
and receive
Wow of the truth
and an air Christian who's been walking
in Christian lives I don't care if it's
30 40 50 60 years but you've never even
walking a workspace life and you've
never really heard anything from the
Lord you you never really fully
understood
and you haven't received the Holy Spirit
all their baptized hired you
please hear me friends
will you be able to stand in the day
legal will you not live your life into
death will you give all to purchase the
pearl of great price would you give all
for that pearl even it means your life
did you give up
revelation 13:7 says and it was given
unto him to make war with the Saints and
to overcome them and power was given
them over all Kindred's and tongues and
nations and it was permitted he was
permitted to wage war against the Saints
and to conquer them was also given
authority over every tribe people nation
language and nation and tongue here is a
call for the endurance of the Saints
those who keep the commandments of God
and you have their faith in Jesus Christ
this is a call to you this calls for
patient endurance
Daniel 721 says as I watch the horn was
waging war against the Saints and
prevailing against them
verse 22 until the Ancient of Days Cain
and pronounces judgment in favor of the
holy people of the Most High and the
time came when they possessed the
kingdom
revelation 19 and 20 19 verse 19 and 20
and I saw the beast and the kings of the
earth and their armies assembled to make
war against him the Ancient of Days who
sat on the horse and against his army
goes with him and the Beast was seized
and with him the false prophet who
performed the signs in his presence by
which he deceived those who had received
the mark of the beast those who
worshipped His image
these were thrown into the lake of fire
which burns with brimstone
revelation 11 7 says when they have
finished their testimony these witnesses
the beast that comes out of the abyss
will make war with him and overcome them
and kill them
there's only two churches that are
called many are called few are chosen
there's only two churches they have been
called to be witnesses and if you don't
think their churches then why would the
Lord refer to the candlesticks is to the
churches when he's describing the stars
in his hand being the spirit seven
spirits of the Lord and the seven
candlesticks being the seven churches
and then turn around and called the two
witnesses two candlesticks why
a candlestick is a candlestick our lamp
stand is a lamp stand
okay so we left off with the two
candlesticks the two lampstands the
stand before the Lord of the earth to
witness for 1260 days there was a few
things I wanted to go over with you and
then I'm going to close the study I was
one of the people who used to think that
we would be raptured right after I got
saved and received the Holy Spirit I
thought you know after I began having
dreams I thought well these these are
like in time I'm having endtime dreams I
didn't even understand why I was having
dreams until I went further in reading
my Bible I was a very new Christian and
at the time I thought well I'm glad I
got saved no I guess I got saved just in
time because the rapture is gonna happen
before all this stuff happens but as I
grew in my relationship with father you
know he he told me of the time in a
dream just when you think you have
arrived it is there that your journey
begins and I woke up and wrote that down
and I'm I'm learning so much in my walk
with him
but I used to think that's you know
based on what I had been taught everyone
knew even if you weren't saved they knew
the church was teaching about the
rapture everybody knew about the rapture
even the non-christians who don't even
believe know because Hollywood has put
out so much be careful what you received
from Hollywood they are not truthful
with the Christians they never intended
to be they want to keep them in a strong
delusion but it is up to us as children
of the Most High our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ it is up to us to seek them
out around there's a scripture and I'll
post it when I find it that I'm thinking
of right now it is up to God to conceal
the matter to conceal a thing it's up to
God to conceal a thing but it's up to
it's a matter of kings to search a
matter out it's the glory of kings to
search a matter out it's in Proverbs
I'll put it up here where you can see
what it correctly says we are to search
the matter out if we don't search for
him diligently how could we know the
truth you're gonna lean on a pastor or
someone else to tell you well are you
gonna search the matter out I'm asking
you today to take this matter that I'm
bringing before you and search it out
with the Lord search it out in the
scriptures don't just pick one or two
I've given you a lot of scriptures today
and there's so many more
but you can't just pick one or two and
decide that's the way it is or believe
the vast majority the road is narrow
it's not wide and gaping it's narrow so
if most of the people thousands and
thousands of views and you know everyone
clicks on something if someone's had a
dream of a perhaps sure I had one that's
had a lot of years yeah one and it
looked like we were going up my flowers
I shared that everyone got excited about
it but the Lord didn't say when he's
showing us the promise of his coming but
until that time we have to stand so I
used to think about the rapture in this
way the same way that most think about
it now but over the past five years of
being saved I have searched the matter
out not just reading of the word but
through prayer I specifically asked
father this was one night in my prayers
this was a couple years ago and I quoted
the scripture to the father in my prayer
I pretty much have it memorized but I'm
gonna read it from the word this is
second Thessalonians 2 chapter 2
now we beseech you brethren by the
coming of our Lord Jesus Christ and by
our gathering unto him that you be not
soon shaken in mind or be troubled
neither by spirit or by word nor by
letter from us as that day of Christ is
at hand let no man deceive you by any
means for that day shall not come except
there come a falling away first and that
man of sin be revealed that son of
perdition it goes on to describe this
man the son of perdition is one that's
it the one that sits on the throne as he
is God he sitteth in the temple of God
showing himself that He is God so in
verse 10 I'll start in verse 9 even him
speaking of this man of sin son
perdition whose coming is after the
working of Satan
remember the dragon gave the Beast his
power whose coming is after the work of
Satan with all power signs and lying
wonders you know Satan doesn't come as
some big fat red devil scary with big
horns and gnarly teeth and vicious
looking you're not gonna know it's him
the word tells us he comes as an angel
of light can you imagine sitting
somewhere and seeing this beautiful
angel appear in all this beauty and
brightness and forgetting everything
that you've learned and not testing the
spirits and entertaining of such I
believe we need to take our dreams a
little bit more seriously I'm learning
and test the spirit
just like everything that we learn is
not from the Lord everything that we
receive and dreams and visions may not
be from the Lord you need to take it a
prayer verse 11 so he comes with
deceiving lying wonders beautiful things
happening wonders things causing fire to
come down from heaven all these things
that the word tells us right and for
this cause I'm sorry burst him and with
all deceivableness and then the perish
because they received not the love of
the truth that they might be saved and
for this cause God shall send them a
strong delusion that they should believe
a lie I wonder what kind of strong
delusion that is that they all might be
damned who believed not the truth but
had pleasure in unrighteousness
the unrighteousness of that scripture I
believe is those of us we're sitting
around waiting setting dates talking
about the Lord coming and we're not even
in prayer for those who are being
slaughtered every single day across the
world their churches are being destroyed
their Bibles are being burned their
businesses are being burnt down they're
fleeing in the middle of the night in
their pajamas they're dying horrific
deaths all over the world yet somehow we
think we're gonna be spared why is that
there was a situation in China many
years ago there was a great slaughter of
the Chinese people and there was a
pasture after that time was over who
survived and he was grieved desperately
in his heart and repenting and severely
grieved because he said he did not warn
or prepare his flock his church he
regretted telling them not to worry
about anything that the Lord was coming
and that they would be raptured I
believe that many pastors in this
country are going to be doing the same
thing war is coming on this soil it's
already here it might not be in your
front in a back yard yet but it's
getting closer and closer as the dates
draw closer
when I mentioned the two candlesticks
the two lampstands they stand before the
Lord of the earth the two churches one
of those churches the churches of
Philadelphia it says and I will make
sure that I get it exactly right here
this is the Church of Philadelphia the
angel - the Church of Philadelphia write
these things saith he that is holy he
that is true he that hath the key of
David he that open it and no man
shutteth and shutteth and no man open
open it I know that works before I have
set before thee an open door that no man
can shut it for thou hast a little
strength and has kept my word and is not
denying my name in verse 10 it says
because thou hast kept the word of my
patience I will also keep thee from the
hour of temptation some versions call it
trial keep you from the hour of trial
which shall come upon all the world to
try them that dwell upon the earth
so tribulation and trial or temptation
it doesn't mean that they will not be in
the tribulation if we look at that
closer and we go to Daniel in verse 10
of chapter 12 many shall be purified and
made white and tried but the wicked
shall do wickedly and none of the wicked
shall understand but the wise shall
understand can you imagine yourself
ministering you are in the tribulation
you haven't been appointed to wrath but
we're appointed we have we are promised
tribulation and we are asked to endure
till the end can you imagine being in
tribulation being built up and your
faith those people which I will get in
the next video being endued with power
on high we'll cover that I believe in
part three be endued with the power on
high just as the disciples were when
they waited and receive the fire of the
Holy Spirit
now they had already received the Holy
Ghost in John chapter 20 when he
breathed on them the Holy Ghost this was
a double portion because within that
forty days when they were waiting or the
fifty days - Pentecost when they were
waiting they received the fire also
and I will go over that in the next
video but when we are witnessing those
who are endued with that power the two
churches that have been called forth
being the two witnesses and like I said
I'll cover this in the next video
there's so much more to this those
people who did not prepare themselves
and are not standing in full armor the
two churches all over the world are
witnessing to these people who were
literally passing out for the fear of
everything men's hearts failing them for
the things that are coming upon the
earth and they are ministering and
there's people being saved the word says
they that be wise shall shine as the
brightness of the firmament and they
that turn many to righteousness as the
stars for ever and ever
can you imagine
the glory and the joy and the
satisfaction of being and this time
being in dude with the power on high and
going forth with your testimony and
witnessing too many yes many will die
during this time and you will at the end
but you were given power to cast out
demons and do all of these things to
heal because you've been dig I did it
though the glory and seen a lost soul
come to the truth knowledge and Jesus
Christ I've heard many many Christians
and I really just couldn't understand it
I had to take it to the Lord many
Christians have said that had dreams or
visions and they're sitting in heaven
looking out of the windows of heaven
they've just been raptured and they're
watching people get destroyed that
breaks my heart this is one of the
reasons why I initially went to father
in prayer and asked him this doesn't
seem right this doesn't seem right at
all but what seemed like to me because I
shared my heart with him about it
then he began to show me but what I
shared with him was I do know it I mean
I want to be with you Father
I do
but I do not want to leave lost souls
well we could be laborers to go forth
and find those people and bring them to
the love of the truth I want to be a
laborer yes I want to be with you but my
heart would break are you really coming
early before this man of sin is revealed
the son of perdition you know that's
what they're saying even pastors the
Lord's coming in at any moment this man
hasn't been revealed he begun to take me
through the scriptures and to show me
the harvest is plenty plentiful it's
plentiful the harvest is plentiful but
the laborers are few
do you love them too
do you love them enough to say I want to
be a laborer and harvest
I want to be
one of those that would reach out in the
very fires with compassion to share
within the truth
I do not think of myself as anything
that's just how I view I don't raise my
cellphone I don't put myself on a
pedestal
I think father Purdon mercy in his love
and I will pick up my cross and I will
follow him will you will you stand with
me and the day of evil like this we
stand in faith in the full armor of God
and having done all stand this is the
conclusion to part two I will be back
shortly with part three I appreciate you
taking the time to listen if you're one
of the ones who are still listening
please take all I have said to prayer
may the Lord bless you may he give you
the eyes and ears to see all the things
that he is teaching us take it to prayer
I love you all Lord bless you and keep
you my face shine upon you and give you
a peace that surpasses all understanding